Hello Freak bitches wouldn't dry ice burn your Dick.
Yeah.
Some people like that shit.
Took 20 years ago I went to a club to get coin lutes and I walked in,
I never forget,
there's was like a,
it was called Ram Rod.
There was a gay bar in the city and we were kids.
We were like 18 that's the first time I seen a dude with a Cape on.
I thought it was the coolest fucking thing in the world.
A man had a cape on and I walked into this club and before we walked in,
there was a fetish club on the side.
There was a guy in a tub that had a sign on them that said a spit on me.
That was his fetish for people to spit on him.
So here's the beauty.
I'm standing there,
you know your jaw is gone,
you're drinking,
you know you had a pee and all a sudden they see 20 guys standing on wine for
the fucking bathroom.
I asked him,
I go,
listen,
why don't you just ask the guy in the tub if we could pay them?
So I walked over to the guys,
look,
can I ask you a question?
Do you mind if we pretend you're the guys?
Go right ahead.
There was a point in that night.
I looked at him,
he had a circle of guys just,
you know those guys that don't want to wait on Line,
like fucking just pee on it.
When I left,
the guy had three inches,
a p in the fucking top.
The sign was all fucking melted,
like the black ink when been melted,
it was this guy wanted people to spit on him.
We ended up pissing on it and I pissed on them.
I'm guilty of I don't give a fuck and suck my dick and I would piss on anybody.
I don't give a fuck.
He seems like the luckiest man alive.
Oh please.
But that's a crazy ass fetish.
But you never know some people's chicken.
Isn't that the men's Gumbo?
You know what I'm saying?
I don't like pissing on myself.
But this guy wanted you to business bid on them.
Wow.
What is that?
That's crazy shit.
That's crazy shit that when I was in Seattle on Wednesday night at the comedy
club,
they had a fetish club afterward and there's a couple of times I stayed people
fucking crazy.
It ain't my bag of tricks,
you know?
But people crazy it.
But like a clips on the nipples and all that.
I might live to that fucking shit,
but some,
some people,
ah,
where's all that should come in from?
What's all that come from?
I don't know the same people on hoarders.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what people fucking come from.
Just a broken brain.
Like someone who just wants to shock the shit out of everybody.
I don't know.
Like sometimes you're sitting there going,
wow,
I need some action in my sex life.
Fucking people in the ass just ain't enough no more.
I still be going around and have people piss all over me.
Yeah.
Like all that shit or down on man,
the light,
my boy,
it's wasn't really the guy that wasn't what the guys in the tensions with.
The guy just wanted people to spit on him.
Wow.
I just took it to the next level.
Okay.